what's up guys I'm Lauren gray at
BuzzFeed and I'm about to take the
Millennial test I think it's gonna be
like beanie babies and stuff things that
I don't know about cuz I was born in
2002 first one is what's the name of
this band I feel like I'll be able to
guess this one New Kids on the Block 98
degrees Hanson or O'Town the only one I
knows New Kids on the Block and that's
from my mom long hair I'm gonna go sneak
it's on the block
that was them Hanson never heard of that
in my life
what's the name of this object from the
game show figure it out called Tommy the
game guy Billy the answer head Charlie
the big head Stevie the clue dude all
right I'm gonna use my my process of
elimination Billy to answer head that's
probably it but it sounds stupid
Tommy the game guy they all sound stupid
I'm just gonna guess I was right
filling the answer head I told you
biggest stupid money what's this movie
called I know this one that's Air Bud
no yes I had that movie on DVD oh my
gosh no what's this toy car ok my friend
Sandi's and it's like a cool trendy
thing a neo pet Tamagotchi talk a hot
cheese or digimon I feel like it's
telling about me I'm doing really good
I'm doing really good it's in it like a
little pet that you like feed and stuff
the myth in a little egg I don't know I
had a DES I played Nintendogs they're
all dead by now
what Spice Girl is this okay I know this
that's baby spice
I knew that she's the blonde one I
didn't listen Spice Girls growing up but
I know the Spice Girls like now I was in
like the weird 2000 space so I listened
to like 303 and Ke$ha and when that was
all popular it was like that that was
your era of music that was like mothers
yeah you know what I mean they like
talked sing
what are these hair accessories called
think they're butterfly Clips cuz that
sounds logical and it was my grandma has
them what computer game is this from the
Oregon Trail the Nevada Trail
the old trail game or the does that's a
cholera sounds like I'm unnecessary it
sounds like the cholera
chronicles it says Marge has cholera on
it the organ trail
boring boring name the Connor Chronicles
one of them better I thought it was well
done
what's this sleek and stylish phone call
it's like my sister had this maybe I
know the razor was an actual phone I'm
gonna guess that I was right okay
who is he Chuck silly Charlie Brown
Doug funnie Dave funky kind of looks
like hi you with hair doesn't one my had
to be addressed that's not Charlie Boone
I guessed it right but that was just
like a wild guess I would have never
gotten that that was unfair
what's this toy called I know this we
had these in school it's a it's a
snippet right yes okay I did have those
oh my gosh find the fake and sing song I
like to make myself look so bad
face Kowboy tearing up my heart digital
get down world wide web of the love the
thing that scares me is that three of
these are actual songs that anythink me
I hope it's not world wide web of love
okay I was right if that wasn't in
singsong then I'm glad I'm not a movie
okay I'm done I got 10 out of 12 right I
did so much better than I thought I was
gonna do that's what I was going for I
was going for a B hi guys it's Lauren
gray I had so much fun here at BuzzFeed
you can check out my new single my story
available everywhere right now and thank
you for watching
[Music]